RICHARD EBERHARDT:
One really great thing
that we're finding
this year is we've
got a large number of women
who are taking the course.
We really try to
focus on getting
a good balance of diversity
of voices in the course.
Of, I think, 65, we're going
to have 25 women first day.
And we're doing
basically this first day
is to see what we can
do to keep them engaged
and keep them as
part of the course.
SARA VERRILI: We have had,
in the last couple of years,
we've had almost twice as many
or three times as many women
on our first day.
And by our second
week, we will be
down to only four or
five women in the class
out of 30 odd people.
So we're really hoping
we can do a better
job at keeping them this year.
PHILIP TAN: And
we're trying a couple
of new techniques this year.
We put a harassment
policy into our syllubus--
as well as an initial
email that went out
to all of the students--
just making it clear
that no, it's not OK to harass
or to make your classmates
feeling uncomfortable.
And if you are in a position
where you feel uncomfortable,
you can always speak
to the instructors.
A lot of this is just
standard MIT policy,
but it's not normal
practice for classes
to actually state it upfront.
Still, we want the
students to understand
that they have these options.
What we also try
to do is make sure
that we have a lot of women
speaking in our classes,
so lecturers, for
instance, or guests.
We try to make sure
that it's very easy
to be able to see yourself
as a professional because all
of our speakers work in games
in some manner or other.
SARA VERRILI: I mean,
we're not entirely sure
why we're losing so many women.
Because it's all
in the beginning.
It's not that we
lose them later on.
The women who go
through our class,
we get a very high percentage
of them coming back
for 617, The Advanced
Game Studio Course.
Once we've got
them in the class,
once they decide it's going
to be an interesting class
to take, we seem to keep them.
The question is how can we
keep from scattering them off
in that first week?
Which is when MIT students
can say, oh, you know what?
This class looks like, I think
I'll go take some other class.
So I think we've
put more of our work
into focusing our upfront making
it clear what the course is
about and trying to make sure
that we are, in fact, being
welcoming.
RICHARD EBERHARDT:
A lot of it has
to do with being welcoming
but also providing challenges
that more people might
be interested in.
So in this case, it's not
necessarily targeting women,
but really just
targeting a diverse group
of voices in the class.
So for this semester,
the design challenge,
we're really focusing on
what the design challenge is
in the class from day one.
Where, in previous semesters,
we talked about a little bit
in the first couple
weeks, and then
we didn't get into it
deeper until midway through.
So in this case,
this semester it's
about decision-making in games.
We're talking about
the types of games
many different kinds
of students would
want to play and have played.
So it's not just that you're
coming to a game course
because you play all sorts of
games, and then you find out,
well this one's just going
to be about war games.
So talking about narrative,
talking about fiction,
also talking about strategy,
talking about chance,
and talking about all of
the different elements
they're going to explore the
next semester in the beginning,
hopefully, we'll
keep them interested.
And then also having a client
in the class where they're
actually making a game
where it's going to do
some good to somebody else.
They're not just making
a game to make a game.
In this case, the
games they're making
are going to be used by the
Red Cross Red Crescent Climate
Centre, particularly to
help policymakers to better
understand the need to devote
resources, time, and money
to disaster preparedness.
So it's a big topic.
It's a timely topic.
Climate change is being
talked about a lot right now.
MIT students like those kinds
of MIT-styled engineering
problems.
So hopefully that also
keeps a good number
of the students keeping in the
course after the first week.
We never have a problem
keeping our number high.
Our numbers are always high.
It's keeping the diverse number
of voices high from the get-go.